عود مره اخرى لمتابعه الانفجار الذي وقع
في السفاره الاوكرانيه في مدريد هذا
الانفجار وقع قرب السفاره وادى الى اصابه
موظفه نتيجه رساله مفخخه وفقا لما نشرته
وكاله روزرز للانباء وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه كوليبا يطالب بزياده حمايه
المباني الدبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه بعد هذا
الانفجار في مدريد هناك همم حاله من
التاهب الامني كما نشاهد في محيط هذه
السفاره سفاره اوكرانيا في مدريد وسط
المطالبات من وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
ديمتريكوليبا بضروره فتحي تحقيق لمعرفه
تفاصيل اكثر حول هذا الانفجار الانباء
تشير الى ان هذا الانفجار وقع نتيجه رساله
مفخخه تم تسليمها للسفاره الاوكرانيه في
مدريد لا حديث الان عن اصابات او وفيات
سواء اصابه واحده ليه موظفه في السفاره
حاله التاهب الامني في محيط السفاره هي
التي همم تسيطر بشكل واضح على المشهد وفقا
الصور التي نراها الان الشرطه الاسلاميه
قالت انه سيتم فتح تحقيق حول هذا الانفجار
بهذه الرساله لنفخخه الى السفاره
الاوكرانيه في مدريد على ما يبدو هذا هو
الهجوم الاول من نوعه الذي يستهدف مقر
الدبلوماسي
لاوكرانيا وهذا ربما يعطي بعض المؤشرات عن
طبيعه التطورات الخاصه بالحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ليست عمليه عسكريه في داخل
الاوكراني فقط ولكن الان يتم الحديث عن
هذه الاستهدافات لمقرات دبلوماسيه همم
اوكرانيه ومن قبل كان هناك ايضا عمليات
اغتيال لشخصيات روسيه داعمه لنظام بوتين
في همم عمليات الاغتيال الشهيره التي تمت
والتي توفيت على اقفليها ابنه كاتب روسي
قريب من بوتين بشكل كبير نحن امام تطورات
تتعلق بالحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه ولكن من
جهه اخرى في استهداف بعمليات ارهابيه
لبعض المقرات الدبلوماسيه